okay I got a loan here I'm on a break
over the course of winter Glen covers
hundreds of miles of extreme terrain in
search of game a high-fat diet is
crucial for his body to keep up this is
the lower right leg from a young bull
moose fifteen or sixteen months old and
I'm gonna break it to get the marrow out
of course you can use a saw to get to
the marrow but I found that by
supporting the bone between two large
rocks and dropping a third Rock on the
center of the bone that that work most
efficiently for me so that's the
technique I'm using well just position
these two rocks here on the ice so that
the bone is supported between the rocks
so what I was looking for is the marrow
this right here this is the good stuff
mmm that is right out of the middle of
that tibia and it's very tasty there's a
lot more in there look at this yeah like
all that's good
marrow in there it's very high in fat
fat Sabine thing around here it's hungry
country it's the Arctic at this time of
year now you know a lot of animals don't
have much fat I mean I eat about a half
a pound of fat a day and if I didn't eat
that much fat I wouldn't be able to eat
enough food because you can only eat so
much meat you actually get poisoned by
too much protein but you can eat a lot
of fat you have to get about seventy
seventy-five percent of your calories
from fat if you don't have carbohydrates
what a day I love that this is eating
out in the Brooks Range fast food smash
something with a couple of rocks and
it's ready to go